aujourd'hui nous allons parler du
programme d'un candidat dont vous avez
peut-être entendu parler dans les médias
emmanuel macron son objectif est plutôt
simple redonner à chaque françaises et
français confiance en eux en la france
en notre capacité collective à relever
nos défis tout ça passe par plusieurs
chantiers l'éducation et la culture
la société du travail la modernisation
de l'économie la sécurité de la nation
et enfin le renouveau démocratique et
l'engagement international eko eko eko
c'est le point principal les programmes
des manuels macron et ça passe par un
plan d'investissement de 50 milliards
d'euros qu'il veut mettre au service de
la qualification des citoyens transition
écologique révolution numérique
modernisation des services publics et
rénovation urbaine pour relancer
l'économie
emmanuel macron souhaite simplifier déjà
pour les entrepreneurs en supprimant le
régime social indépendant donc le rsi et
en réduisant les charges ensuite plus
globalement pour les indépendants en
laissant aux artisans et commerçants le
choix d'opter pour le régime fiscal de
la micro entreprise
ensuite d'un côté au niveau des
employeurs il réduit les cotisations
sociales pour faciliter l'embauché et
l'autre côté au niveau des salariés
il crée un bonus malus sur l'assurance
chômage ce qui fait payer plus de
charges aux employeurs qui abusent des
contrats courts pour ce qui est de
l'impôt et le simplifier aussi en
mettant l'impôt sur les sociétés à 25%
en transformant les sf en impôt sur la
fortune immobilière et en créant un
prélèvement unique de 30 % sur les
revenus du capital
c'est un des leurs revenus liée à la
rente au genre immobilière mais aussi
financière en ce qui concerne le
dialogue social les principes
fondamentaux comme les 35 heures ou le
smic reste dans la loi mais seul quand
même que l'organisation du travail ou
des horaires puisse être négocié dans
chaque société par un accord majoritaire
ou suite à un référendum d'entreprise et
enfin parce qu'elle la lutte contre la
fraude fiscale et sociale
il l'a renforce et imposent les grands
groupes de l'internet sur leur chiffre
d'affaires réalisé sur notre sol sociale
emmanuel macron soin de faire de la
lutte contre la discrimination en
priorité nationale en multipliant les
contrôles aléatoires à grande échelle
qui soit pour l'emploi ou l'accès au
logement et en publiant les noms des
entreprises qui ne respectent pas
l'égalité salariale entre les femmes et
les hommes
il souhaite aussi modifié la relation
que les français ont aujourd'hui avec le
chômage l'idée c'est que même les
salariés qui démissionnent puissent en
bénéficier
une fois tous les cinq ans mais aussi
les artisans indépendants entrepreneurs
buteur ou professions libérales la
contrepartie est temps que le refus d'un
certain nombre d'offres entraîne l'arrêt
des allocations pour les retraites il
veut mettre fin aux injustices des
différents régimes existants
l'idée étant que pour chaque euro cotisé
tout le monde et le droit à la même
pension il ne souhaite d'ailleurs pas
retouché l'âge de départ à la retraite
ni le montant des pensions sécurité
emmanuel macron souhaite recruter dix
mille policiers et gendarmes
supplémentaires pour mettre en place une
police de sécurité quotidienne
il souhaite aussi donner aux policiers
un nouveau pouvoir sous le contrôle d'un
juge celui d'interdire un délinquant
l'axé un quartier où il a commis un
délit et déclare la politique de
tolérance zéro contre les incivilités du
quotidien qui pourront être punissable
d'amande immédiate et dissuasive
par ailleurs toute peine désormais
prononcée devrait être exécuté et comme
il est dans une logique d'innovation ils
souhaitent aussi imposer cyberdéfense et
cyber sécurité comme priorité cologie
emmanuel macron veut diviser par deux le
nombre de jours de pollution
atmosphérique
pour cela il propose une prime de 1000
euros pour inciter les citoyens qui ont
un véhicule polluant en changer il
souhaite aussi faire de la france le
leader mondial de la recherche sur la
transition environnementale et dans la
lutte contre les pesticides et
perturbateur endocrinien qui sont pour
lui une des principales causes de
l'augmentation des cancers des enfants
jettent aussi d'ici à 2022 que 50% des
produits proposés par les cantines
scolaires et les restaurants
d'entreprise soient bio écologiques ou
issus de circuits courts diplomatie pour
protéger l'europe
il souhaite réserver l'accès aux marchés
publics européens aux entreprises qui
localise au moins la moitié de la
production en europe dans le cadre d'un
bail
youpi actes ainsi que la mise en place
d'un mécanisme de contrôle des
investissements étrangers en europe pour
pouvoir préserver les secteurs
stratégiques
par ailleurs il souhaite une lutte
accentué contre les arrangements fiscaux
entre les pays européens et les
multinationales comme cela a pu avoir
lieu entre apple et l'irlande démocratie
emmanuel macron est partisan d'une
grande loi de moralisation de la vie
publique et il ya du boulot
l'idée c'est d'interdire aux
parlementaires des activités de conseil
à côté de leur mandat pour éviter les
conflits d'intérêts imposés
l'intégralité de leurs indemnités et la
suppression de leur régime spécial de
retraite dont on a eu l'occasion de
parler ensemble sans précédent épisode
l'interdiction de toute embauche par un
élu ou un ministre dame
de sa famille l'interdiction du cumul de
plus de trois mandats identique
successifs l'interdiction pour tous les
détenteurs d'un casier judiciaire niveau
b2 de se présenter à une élection et la
présentation par le présent la
république de son bilan national et
européen
une fois par an devant le congrès enfin
il souhaite impliquer plus les citoyens
en demandant aux parlementaires de
mettre en place des dispositifs
innovants d'évaluation du travail
parlementaire et législatif
un jury citoyen compte rendu de mandat
via les réseaux sociaux etc tout en
encourageant les communes à développer
les budgets participatifs c'est-à-dire à
consulter directement les citoyens sur
l'utilisation de l'argent public comme
d'habitude dans les sources le lien vers
son programme complet et comme
d'habitude je vous invite à le consulter
parce qu'en cinq minutes on passe
forcément à côté de certains points on
se retrouve très vite pour le ou les
prochains candidats
j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu
n'hésitez pas à partager si c'est le cas
retrouvez aussi des décryptages sur la
chaîne de l'ami hugo décrypte merci à
tous les types heures pour soutenir
financièrement le projet on se revoit
bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo love
peace